BACK, WHAT A STRIP BY HOLIDAY.
AND TO COMBINE THAT WITH A PASS
OVER THE TOP WHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO MAKE TWO FREE THROWS,
JUST BEAUTIFUL BASKETBALL BY THE
BUCKS.
>> Mike: ANTETOKOUNMPO,
32 POINTS, 9 REBOUNDS, 6 ASSISTS
AND HE'S WITH MALIKA.
>> THANKS SO MUCH, MIKE.
GIANNIS, WALK ME THROUGH THAT
STEAL FROM JRUE HOLIDAY THAT LED
TO THAT BUCKET THAT END UP
SEALING YOU THE GAME.
>> YOU KNOW, BIG-TIME STEAL BY
HOLIDAY, AND GREAT PASS.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE PASS WAS
ALL ABOUT TRUST.
OBVIOUSLY HE COULD HAVE PULLED
THE BALL OUT, LET THE CLOCK RUN
AND GET A GOOD SHOT, BUT HE
TRUST ME.
THREW THE BALL OUT THERE, AND --
GOOD PLAY BY HOLIDAY.
>> YOU HAVE HAD A BIG INDIVIDUAL
NIGHT IN THIS SERIES.
CHRIS HAS HAD A BIG INDIVIDUAL
BUT FOR YOU, DREW, AND CHRIS TO
ALL GET GOING AT ONE TIME, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IT MEANS A LOT.
IT WAS THE GAME FOR US TO GET
GOING, ALL THREE OF US.
WE PLAYED GOOD BASKETBALL.
WE KEPT OUR COMPOSURE.
CAME BACK FROM 16.
THESE ARE THE FINALS.
YOU GOT GIVE EVERYTHING YOU GOT.
>> WE SAW YOU GIVE EVERYTHING
YOU HAVE.
WE SAW YOU PUT YOUR HANDS ON
YOUR KNEES AT THE END.
KHRIS MIDDLETON TOLD ME HE WAS
HOPING YOU GUYS WOULD STEAL THIS
ONE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WIN IT ALL IN FRONT OF YOUR
FANS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY NOW IS THIS.
>> ONE MORE TO GO.
ONE MORE TO GO.
WE HAVE TO PLAY GOOD BASKETBALL.
JUST GOT KEEP PLAYING GOOD
BASKETBALL AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET A WIN.
>> WHAT DO YOU PERSONALLY TASK
YOURSELF WITH OVER THE NEXT FEW
DAYS TO PREPARE FOR ARGUABLY THE
BIGGEST GAME OF YOUR CAREER?
>> JUST RECOVER.
FAMILY TIME, REST, GET AWAY FROM
BASKETBALL, AND WHEN WE GET BACK
HERE, WE GOT TO BE READY.
GOT TO BE READY AS A TEAM, PLAY
GOOD BASKETBALL, MOVE THE BALL,
BE PHYSICAL LIKE WE DID TONIGHT,
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
OURSELVES IN A POSITION TO WIN
THE GAME.
BUT WE CANNOT WORRY ABOUT THAT
NOW.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF OUR BODY
AND GET